this week Activision officially launched  the call of duty world and today we are  proud to announce that Sony Playstation  will be the official presenting partner  of the Call of Duty World League season  for black ops 3 you know how pumped are  you are beyond excited throughout the  Call of Duty World League season the  best teams in the world will compete to  qualify for the call of duty  championships through either the pro or  challenge divisions Activision and Sony  Playstation are co-funding the 3 million  dollar worldwide prize pool make dessert  with the drone he's going to use that  over  pro division qualifications are  currently under way across the globe so  tune in now to experience all of the  action  you  please do